foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah it's good to be here in person once
again
yeah welcome back thanks welcome back
thanks this is this is the first time
I've been on the podcast yeah welcome
back it's the first time I've been on
the podcast and you've been here yeah I
think it's strange are you sure I'm
pretty sure
I have no memory of anything else I'm
just a figure on the television is this
like meeting a celebrity right now it's
like oh my gosh you're here all right I
don't know can I tour your studio uh we
don't have really the infrastructure for
tours could I just come in though first
you can take a picture on the street he
told me the same thing better it's okay
people do ask that unfortunately we
can't do tours
um that's just something we're not
really equipped for we can't do tours or
tours however you say it we can't do it
the tour the scale of data
data skill of data data the scale of my
data yeah he's so big scale of Dada we
are gonna we do want to do the scale of
your mama jokes
I want to try to get Ren to do that next
I feel like it's Gotta come out like
around April we already have an idea for
that one what was that one going to be
is that a surprise or no we can talk
about it we were talking about it on
Monday oh yeah
um
we put Ray Leota
yeah we released a video called we put
Ray Liotta and Goodfellas we Deepak
someone else into his spot yeah and then
paint a Clean Plate and then show the
process
the premise is like look I really Oda is
such a good actor he's like the
quintessential you know like
Italian-American character like he's so
good yeah I don't know why they didn't
put him in why didn't they put him and
we're just convinced that he's not in
the movie and we have all these scenes
and he's not in the movie We're
replacing with like Martin Sheen or
something I don't know some other random
person and and then we yeah that's the
idea it's gonna be great I love it yeah
so there you go we already have our
April Fool's thing ready now we can move
on Scalia Mama Ren did say in the video
next up was scale of explosions though
yeah he called his shot already well I
mean you know we can change his mind
if we work together yeah
um speaking of explosions we're gonna be
filming a video tomorrow about CGI
explosions versus practical explosions
yeah you can get a little preview on
this podcast you can practice a little
bit oh I like that I like that a lot
because one of the reasons we're making
this video much like our muzzle flashes
video is because we are well me
specifically I I wish to see better CGI
explosions explosions are like my first
love in cinema uh Nico came out of the
womb and said better CGI yeah
yeah it's like you'll find out yeah
you'll understand soon because like we
see it you know these days our biggest
explosions with like simulation programs
like Houdini and stuff but it's just it
lacks that punch it lacks that it lacks
lacks a lot of things honestly and I
kind of want to get into it and like
figure out why I mean like just for my
research so far like the the way pyro
technicians do explosions General like
your your general Fireballs is you have
like some shaped thing to like shape the
direction of the explosion usually it's
like a frying pan yeah like a wok
basically
um you know they'll usually has a little
more like heavy duty than like a 15 walk
from Target but you know that idea a
metal like a metal shaped cone thing
and they have what's called a lifter
which is their explosive charge uh they
just call it a lifter probably not to
Spook people but it's a bomb
uh and then on top of that lifter is
gasoline or you know it really depends
what you're trying to do but if you're
doing a fireball it's gasoline like yeah
you know it's a block bag or something
like that yeah they usually do it by by
gallon or you know and then it's like oh
you want a two gallon and then they'll
literally just put it on top of it like
a one of those old school ice packs
yeah yeah be careful though because
gasoline needs through plastic very fast
yeah so
um anyways they you know when it comes
time to do your big effect you light the
the charge the lifter it blows up and
throws all the gasoline into the air and
that's the key because he ever lit
gasoline on fire it just burns on the
surface right so how do you get the
fireball well you need to atomize it you
need to basically spray it into the air
and so you're using explosive to do that
then a byproduct of that is that after
the gasoline's been sprayed into the air
you know they're still burning embers in
part of the explosive is hot and that
ignites the gasoline at least at its
base and then that flame Burns through
this big like droplet cloud of gasoline
giving you a fireball and so you
actually have a really complicated
process happening there where you have a
bomb that lifts liquid fuel into the air
and then part of that liquid fuel
ignites and that ignition then moves
through the liquid Fuel and it's not
like there's a match that moves to the
fuel it's literally part of the fuel
starts on fire and as that fire expands
it lights the rest of the fuel on fire
and it burns the fuel that way so you
get a really this really interesting
Dynamic flow and usually there's more
than one explosion going off at the same
time movies whereas like with CGI
explosions you can do it that way but
most people don't really do it that way
most people just kind of go spray hot
fire and you get like bubbly hot fire
that like expands and lifts rather than
like a fuel source that sprays out using
effectively and we have to follow fluid
dynamics first Like Water Dynamics and
then you go through and you ignite that
on fire with fire Dynamics like yeah I
mean how do you do approach explosions
in Houdini I mean that's the the thing
you kind of hit the nail on the head
right out the gate is
it the there's an understanding that the
source is just as important as
everything that takes place after that
but I feel like there's a lot of
attention on everything that takes place
after so what I mean about sources like
the actual emission sources for example
if we're gonna like emit an actual
burning fire just doing it on like a
static sphere you're going to get this
perfectly you know symmetrical emission
yeah yeah it does the like that's
consistent if you then if you you know
instead
um create a noise pattern that it exists
and is random on the surface that is
like emitting different temperatures in
different areas now you get a mission of
like something more interesting and
intricate and then if you also do that
with the shape like if the shape is
changing and undulating and changing you
get something even more interesting so I
thought you just took an element and
then just dropped it onto the frame like
an already pre-existing yeah like you
see in all those things on the Instagram
ads where they just drag and drop it and
it's tracked into the shot too like yeah
yeah it's I mean that's how you did it
quite yeah it's quite an involved
process and like after the source side
of it then you actually have to dictate
you know how long the temperature lives
right like how how long until it cools
off the turbulence of the temperature
that is emitting the density of this
smoke and the pressure that's expanding
and how much pressure in what area like
there's so much fine-tuned work that's
required and I feel like a lot of that
Focus comes before an understanding of
what is an actual bomb like how does it
because I didn't I didn't know that like
I've messed around a little bit with
explosions not too much but I do Wonder
to what extent you know the creators on
a lot of these shows and stuff are
educated and actually what is happening
yeah I mean I'm sure some are but I
think the vast majority either aren't or
just it's faster just like build your
emitter and just be like okay it's going
to increase the amount of fire and heat
very fast and expand very fast and I
turn it down
and that's with pressure yeah yeah so
the way that pressure works right in
this voxel state is it's just a
perfectly out outwards directional Force
which is that bubble that blue yeah and
it is it's the it's the key framing of
like big pressure drop it and it goes it
rolls out and then starts to fold in on
itself yeah and it's like a Houdini
cauliflower yeah and the popcorn that
you see in the smoke and like there's
there's lots of ways to break that up
um that are more technical but at the
very core of it it's the source right
like if I create a really cool technique
that I saw from my friend Urban brodesco
really talented like explosion guy uh
it's a source of like he would actually
emit almost like um a grain simulation
exploding which is like clumpy and like
gritty like dirt and he would use that
as the emission source for the density
so you get this beautiful Randomness
that like pushes through and you get the
streaks of smoke that like fly out you
need bits of the book you need all of it
and it's it's so there's so much to it
and it takes forever to iterate too
um at least in the traditional working
we're moving in the right direction
there
um like liquid stuff like Axiom yeah
yeah the Axiom Sovereign Houdini
ambergen Emergen is like obviously a
standalone third-party you know
simulator which is borderline real time
which is incredible and I'm a Houdini
boy I try to be in Houdini for as much
as I possibly can an axiom is a new
third-party solver inside of Houdini
that is also borderline real time and
it's phenomenal like the the speed
increase I feel like an artist again
using it because that's always been my
thing with flip which is like water
simulation and fire simulation is you
push play on a simulation and you just
you have to walk away you have to walk
away for 45 minutes an hour to even see
one iteration of what you've done yeah
and then you go okay what do I want to
change for this next 45 minute test and
you just eventually go it's good enough
let's just move and I feel like that's
what's happening in the post pipeline is
guys we did not a lot enough time for
this it's good enough and and that gets
pushed out and then we watch it and we
feel kind of icky about it surprised
that they haven't done updates uh to to
sort of
utilize that
um
you know like having of the render so so
it's gonna say oh well instead of just
hitting it and 45 minutes come back you
know and then if you like that one then
do a full res version of it I'm
surprised they haven't
introduced like programmatic language to
say okay let's let's do this in like
fractured ways so that you can see it in
real time well yeah it's it's
interesting that you say that because
there there are like some hacked
solutions to that to some degree but
it's not like you know upping the
resolution of a 2D image if you have the
resolution of the voxel count the flow
because the way that it works with
voxels is they all contain a little bit
of information and when you're solving
frame by frame what is coming next the
computer is looking at what happened the
frame before and moving like the density
value through the neighboring voxels
yeah if you double the value on all four
axes right it changes that flow yeah
because now there's way more to navigate
through it it changes the entire
aesthetic of yeah it doesn't just
explode higher resolution yeah yeah it
actually changes the which is one of the
more frustrating parts that's like a I
mean that's just a math equation at a
certain point it's a very complex yeah
of course I mean but that's what
computers are for yeah solving solving
those problems so yeah what's cool about
Axiom is you can get to like borderline
render ready resolution in almost real
time yeah and it's I don't understand it
I've talked to the guys who made it and
I'm like guys I don't know what you're
doing keep doing it and do it for flip
next please because like it makes you
feel I almost thought back to the video
that that Ren and I did on the stained
glass man how they started iterating
tools to animate characters that were
artist focused and up until now it feels
like it's it's been more you know code
focused and people who really like hyper
specialize in it to where it's not been
accessible and it does feel like we're
starting down the path of something
being way more accessible but at the
same time like the vast majority of
stuff that you see yeah is lacking it's
it's you see it's popcorny or you see
the voxel cubes because they didn't have
time to up the resolution for the
renders and shading it is a whole nother
thing to get like good realistic you
know flow of of a mission Through the
flames from like a transparent core and
there's there's so much to it that it's
it's a lot yeah so with all that goes
into it Nico if you were directing
something
would you a lot
a massive post-production schedule and
VFX budget
to have everything simulated or if
possible I would try to do it forever I
love explosions at the very least below
it like maybe the fireball is not real
but blow it apart on set for real like
get some air cannons like you know it
you can't do explosions in your place
that's fine get some American it's like
I don't get a trash bag full of dust and
blow that everywhere like it doesn't
matter that much just like get real
stuff on set because it's some it's as
simple as like watching smoke wrap
around the corner of a wall or something
like that you know it's like you need to
see that it's part of the environment
and that's what like a lot of just the
basic compositing like we just here's my
fire element here's my explosion on it
I'm gonna stick it on top it doesn't
interact with the environment like you
need that interaction you need those
perspective shifts winter is coming
ladies and gentlemen and that means
you're gonna need something to keep your
feet dry and warm all winter long and
courtesy of today's sponsor vessi we've
got just the thing or you now what is so
special about these that makes them
better than your current pair of winter
sneakers well these are made from a
patented Diamond text material which
means your feet are going to be warm all
winter long they're also 100 waterproof
meaning that you can wear them through
snow sleet mud you could wear them all
day long and your feet are still going
to be feeling good and smelling good
when you take the shoe off and in
addition to that they use less material
in the knitting process and the creation
of this shoe and there are no animal
products meaning that they're 100 vegan
now you might be wondering Jake why does
everybody in the studio wear vessies
well for all of the reasons I just
mentioned and in addition look at how
flexible these things are you could you
could ball these up with a rubber band
and and and and bend them this way I
mean they're like you could bend them
that way look at that look at that
listen if you click the link in the
description below you'll get 25 off each
pair of vessi shoes that you order just
go to vesi.com Corridor cast or click
the link in the description below for 25
off I mean that's that's a great start
to a good thing on your feet huge thanks
to them for sponsoring and now let's get
back to the conversation you know what's
really interesting one of the things
that like really stood out to me as I
was doing the research and looking at
real explosions was when they're setting
off the the lifters the explosives it
creates pressure shock waves and the
pressure shock wave changes the color of
the fire so the fire will be like you
know like you know coming out the
fireball will be glowing and be like you
know orange and red and they'll set off
another lifter and you'll see the fire
Go flash to Yellow as everything like
changes pressure inside then go back to
Orange so cool yeah there's so much to
it yeah there's so much to it so so much
to it that's always like that's that's
the benefit of even if you can only do a
tiny little explosion on set at least
you have some sort of like practical
reference of how it looks through that
camera in that environment and like then
if you do have to simulate or use like
2D compositing elements at least you
have that thing to match to that you're
like oh sweet we know the color value
exactly how it's going to look how it
might light up the environment all that
stuff it's a big thing with like a lot
of CGI explosions like the shape of an
explosion is important right you want a
big Fireball curling up like mushroom
clouds you want blasting out the sides
like you know the sides of a window as
if like you're having like a you know a
building like a building at base level
exploding you know or like a car
explosion with the explosion going at
the sides of the Windows like what shape
do you want and a lot of times when
people are shaping explosions in CGI
it's through the use of like texture
maps and pressure differences and things
like that
and in reality the shape of an explosion
doesn't come from a pressure increase
and it doesn't come from like you know
if actually blowing up a balloon and
having that balloon pop uh which is what
you get in a lot of CGI explosions which
is why they're very round at the
beginning in reality the shape is coming
from the liquid like if you want to it's
from the from the fuel and if you want
to shape your explosion what you need to
First do is a fluid simulation a splash
you need to Splash your liquid and
that's going to give you the spikes and
the spiers and the clouds of droplets
that then the fire can move through
because the other thing is like those
droplets was Liquid they have inertia
they have movement so as the fire moves
through that there's flowing air that's
also then pushing and distorting things
but like to be like okay you're gonna do
an explosion simulation so the first
thing you need you to do is simulate
water yeah and I was like well why would
I do that yeah it's like because that
gives you the shape of the explosion you
Splash your water and then you light it
on fire yeah and it's yeah and it's it's
kind of the same idea with the grain
simulator is the right way to go about
it's that's that is the right way to do
it yeah because like the the way that
grains work is it's basically just like
a particle simulator in a way they just
have relationships to each other and
their neighbors so you can like say oh
you know be bonded to your neighbor this
strength and only that strength will
break them apart but if you have a big
emissive velocity that kind of explodes
everything you get the individual
particles they atomized right gasoline
or whatever but you also get the clumps
too you get like a real diverse set of
of stuff and if you give those same
points that are exploding fuel that will
ignite at a certain temperature and then
you emit that temperature from the core
and it catches fire and the the
temperature travels through all these
particles they'll all ignite yeah and
it's it's like we have tools to do that
it's just again the education of yeah
knowing however the time the time to do
it and iterate know-how and the
computers like specs yeah so when you
when you um
explode an emitter in a physics Sim does
that does that effectively function the
same way as the lifter in in actuality
in in the same in in physics because in
if you ignited a lifter the my
presumption is that you have a bag over
a lifter the pressure
at which it explodes is going to exceed
the velocity as it push of it as it
pushes outward so it's gonna that's how
it's gonna ignite everything because if
it all moved out at the same velocity
then it would just be like a water
simulation because then none of the fuel
would actually catch that's actually
what it looks like for the first couple
frames of explosion it does Splash it
literally like it's like those wave
rides at the you know at the music park
with like the the you know Bolt full of
people hits the waves whoosh and all the
water splashes out that's what the first
three to four frames of an explosion
look like and the fire there's no fire
catches up it catches up
so it
okay so well that's interesting yeah
because I guess it's pushing against the
air so then eventually that would slow
it down but the fire is burning faster
yep so it would catch up yeah and the
other interesting thing is with real
explosions it's not all the fuel Burns
at least not right away in fact as the
flame expands it pushes the fuel so you
end up with his like these droplets that
are now on the surface the explosion
that aren't creating bulbous explosions
but they become they're creating licks
of flame as last bits of droplets light
on fire that kind of got pushed out and
they kind of like rained down around it
too so you have all this interesting
texture on the outside of the fire you
have all these licks of fire that once
again in simulated Fireballs you tend to
get really smooth surfaces yeah and
you're always trying to fight against
that exactly well there are like some
methods for that too it's called
advection right fuel infection and there
are ways to advect like the fuel that
you're burning actually projected out
based on the velocity of what's
exploding so it'll actually push that
fuel that isn't yet burned and that will
also catch up as like a secondary flame
burn that triggers at some point or
maybe doesn't it's all kind of just
dependent on what you've The Source
again coming back to the source of what
you've built it dictates everything and
like the popcorning too right the idea
of there being these smooth like friggin
bulbous bubbles of smoke yeah like if if
smoke is moving through the atmosphere
right it's moving through the actual
turbulent wind that exists in the
atmosphere but also the fast-moving
smoke is coming into contact with like
these micro
Divergent air currents that's creating
like a Rippling on the surface of the
smoke and there's ways to do that too
now which is awesome yeah it's crazy
because that was a big thing that we
were at least missing back in the day
with like fume effects was like there
wasn't air until the voxels started
growing from your explosion but in
reality there's already a bunch of air
everyone's already air and so like we
would go in and we'd like we'd have a
fuel pass or like a heat pass and we'd
activate all the voxels and start gas
flowing through them but we have it be
invisible so you can see it so as the
fire would move through it there's
already voxels there that had turbulence
and then the fire was existing in this
imperfect world and you get chaos as
opposed to just a smooth bulbous
containing in the back it's ugly yeah so
the way that we like kill it is with
something called disturbance and that's
basically yeah it's like a couple voxels
out like this really tiny strong you
know force that breaks up and creates
these really interesting ripples on the
surface of the smoke and it makes all
the difference in the world and it's
cool because you know in Houdini
especially it tracks every attribute of
everything that's going on like you have
full access to all the data and that's
great because what you can do is you can
find the fastest moving part of your
source and the slowest moving and map
the disturbance to only affect the
fastest moving so that it's not
disturbing things that are kind of just
slowly moving through the air we can
leave that to the turbulence of the
atmosphere but the fast moving we can we
can shatter that a bit like try to pop
the bubbles yeah before they get too big
and ugly you know you gotta hope you
have all your settings right before you
walk away for an hour yeah but yeah
honestly but now like again Axiom I just
I love it to death like I'm watching it
I'm literally watching it happen and
it's it's almost render are ready
resolution you use Axiom for all the
back roll fire right for all the bad
girl fire yeah so good and I really I
really pushed it on the scale I know I
didn't optimize it but but again it was
just I I wouldn't have been able to do
that without it so I love the direction
we're going like it's really encouraging
I mean the big breakthrough for me with
like the whole CGI explosions thing was
the fact you could have smoke finally in
your composite because like for the
longest time if you're dealing with an
explosion element you know you get a
real explosion element
but unless you filmed on a green screen
and pulled a perfect key which is really
kind of impossible with fire and smoke
there's no way to like how do you cut
out the fire and the smoke to put on top
of other footage like okay so the smoke
is going to be black and gray and
semi-transparent so maybe against like a
blue sky or a green screen but then you
have the fire which like really bright
really hot and like that makes sense for
like a Luma key you can't Luma key the
fire and keep the smoke because the
smoke is black and so at the end of the
day you're like well I guess I'll shoot
explosions on a green screen and like
you so you can't really do that and even
like the closest we got is action VFX
finally went out and did some explosions
against the blue sky and pulse are
really good keys but it was a ton of
work and most people weren't doing that
if you did it in CGI you can walk away
with a perfect Alpha channel for
explosion a perfect Alpha Channel and
all the passes that exist in an exr
right everything that you could possibly
want isolate the Fire or the emission
completely create mats from that if you
want like have full Direction Over the
depth of smoke like the flexibility
afforded like if we can just get to the
point where it's more attainable for the
average generalist to yeah because
execute that's the biggest is just the
like barrier to entry on it still is
like you still have to invest so much
time
to get it past the point where it's like
that popcorn explosion it's true then
it's like uh you know what those action
VFX elements look pretty sweet yeah
um and even still once you get there
like I've my process on all that has
always been like I don't know if I've
ever just used
a simulation in a shot I've done it's
always like uh it gives in a little bit
of dust element in there that gets shot
out and like like Embers or uh like what
I used to do is to try to break up that
popcorn feeling it's like if you take an
actual essentially just the emission
pass of that because ideally you'd have
like an emissive aov and use that as
essentially your Alpha mat for an actual
like gas explosion element and that's
how that has that break you're putting
real gas explosion texture yeah and
using the fake explosion as a mask yeah
kind of softening the mat out a little
bit and the smoke and you can end up
getting some nice results where
you have basically the alpha matte of
your simulated explosion even though it
looks a little bit popcorny but then you
have like the Practical elements in
there blended with it and it's like oh
sweet okay now it's starting to get some
of those actual real world uh kind of
attributes and stuff it's I don't know
that's where the like
compositing magic comes in where you're
like okay sweet we didn't get it all the
way there but now how can we like get it
across the Finish Line yeah and I mean
it always comes back to the same idea of
it's best when VFX and practical blend
yeah that's that's its Perfect final
form is the marriage of the two yeah
it's not one of the other yeah I know I
think people forget about that yeah it's
it really is both yeah
[Music]
um
you just
need to utilize the strengths of both
yeah yeah um because obviously it's
mainly impractical to do
hey we're gonna blow up a 30-story
building yeah yeah I mean you can do a
model yeah but you know also if you do a
model you have these other limitations
time cost
so many takes yeah yeah and you can't
just walk away for 45 minutes and then
come back and have another model built
and blow it up again right yeah um so
that's a constraint but if you
you know if you combine the two that's
really where things start to look and
feel real in a practical way for the
artist yeah yeah I mean like one of the
big issues too is performance right of
people who are reacting to an explosion
you get them on green screen with some
leaf blowers in their faces like they're
not going to heat and you're not gonna
see the terror like yeah they're hot
they're hot
until it hits you man then that wave
hits you yeah uh so that's something you
can't recruit filming uh this um
what was that one the one where we we
did the first fire effect where we let
that guy fail on fire that was shock
troopers shock troopers and uh so we had
these they weren't gas explosions they
were uh like mortars mortars and uh they
were like 10 pound mortars or something
they were big
and they were buried in the ground and
they were to shoot up and so samaniko
had this very particular path that they
were supposed to run along and uh you
know Joe basically the guy the Pyro guy
just said well these are going to be
concussive so don't forget to act and
they were both they were both like yeah
got it you know no big deal take you
know roll it and and they're running and
boom one goes off and then the other one
goes off kind of close to Sam yes and
Sam
just had a natural reaction to it of a
very concussive 10-pound mortar going
off next to him and he's in the middle
and it's it's like 60 or 120 frames a
second he kind of like slows down and
then he drops down and he like looks
around and
he real okay and he realizes
so that was a that was the first uh
experience at least for me of seeing uh
okay you do you kind of have to go
through it to understand what's going to
happen but so that you don't mess up the
next time
um same thing with fire because it is
super hot but it goes away quick when
it's gas yeah super hot and then it's
not yeah yeah and the lighting that that
emits too depending on the scene from
explosions is so nice it's so nice and
it's so like complex because it's a
spreading light source so the Shadows
are like depending on where you are
they're like start sharp and soften out
like is it spread they're so like yeah
you just go on forever with all the
different things to keep in mind and
it's just I don't think it's feasible to
to do that at least not right now but
we're gonna do our best in this video to
like lay out all the steps so that all
future VFX compositors and CGI artists
and simulators can be like all right
here's all the steps I need to actually
mimic a real explosion now whether or
not to take the time to do it or have
the resources you know until this
current iteration of Technologies no
longer yeah you know the right tool for
it right but yeah yeah
it's a fun topic though I feel like I
honestly feel that way about most
simulated things yeah but but I feel
like explosions is really the I feel
like poster boy for that explosion is
the biggest offender where if you're
watching even like the biggest budget
Hollywood movie you can still be like uh
yeah that's Houdini no I mean that's you
see it with you see it with like flip
fluid simulations too when they're
they're pretty globular yeah like you
know what I mean like you see the mesh
hanging on and the kind of like thick
holes and stuff you see that a lot and
like uh we've come a long way there too
like I you're not watching Lord of the
Rings not yet you're not watching Lord
of the Rings no you're not watching Lord
of the Rings okay well I'm watching Lord
of the Rings you know and the visual
effects are insane especially the water
stuff man they're doing ocean work that
is just like freaking chef's kiss and it
gets me so pumped like really inspiring
stuff so House of the Dragon has some
pretty sweet explosions oh you get you
okay that's pretty sweet heck yeah some
dragoning explosions well that's that
was going to be my question is is does
anything come to mind that like did meet
man
I don't think I've ever seen a CGI
explosion that I thought was better than
the real thing or did you realize it was
I'm pretty on top of what cgiers I'm
looking at what did you think about the
expected you gotta go on react maybe
you can trick me I don't think you'll be
able to to be honest how did you think
of any off the top of my head well there
there's some there's like some aerial
explosions in Star Wars that I thought
were super tasty
um like the newer Star Wars films
obviously those are weird because then
it's in outer space and you're like no
this was on a planet I mean yeah
there are sims that are super fun to
watch hey there's chippy yeah
he's been up there since we've had the
green screen photography awesome yeah
you know like the death star shooting
stuff in Rogue one like those are six
shots like don't get me wrong they're
super sick shots we're like the wall
collapsing in like season seven of Game
of Thrones like those Sims are awesome
and they're super cool watch like it's
like watching a giant stack of Legos or
not Legos dominoes fall over right it's
basically the same exact feeling but
watching a stack of dominoes fall over
it's not the same feeling as watching an
explosion go off so that's the one thing
about the physics Sims like they're they
can be super intricate and beautiful to
look at but yeah I can't think of any
like simulated explosion
that like made me go wow like real
explosions have you know like when I
think about like the Empire State
Building blowing up in Independence Day
yeah it's like oh there's just so much
to it like yeah yeah that's so pretty
good yeah yeah yeah there's just so much
going on and all the little pieces that
blow off and yeah it's hard to
registering the timing the Rhythm to it
yeah it's like it's like playing an
instrument you know boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom it's like you know
it's like Rhythm and like scale and like
you know accents no they do a bridge
explosion and bad boys too or maybe
that's not bad boys but there's
yeah but that's done with minis or
models we always talk about the
explosion from stealth yeah and below
the door oh that cars
they go flying back did you guys watch
uh light and Magic I love that man so
I'm not quite done with it yet but um
have you gotten to the part where they
go through I think it's Poltergeist the
house implosion yeah where they have
double barrel shotgun
to break it up they spent like have you
watched it yet they spend was it like
like six six months building one model
of the house and it's as they're
building it all the individual little
pieces that are supposed to emulate like
the lumber in the walls they have those
tied to like these threads and basically
they have this it needs to implode yeah
into essentially a vacuum that they have
at the back of this practical model
house wow and then they had two shotguns
rigged up in case it doesn't like start
to go all the way through that they'll
just blast it and it was like a one take
like we only got one shot yes if we want
to do this again it's gonna cost
hundreds of thousands and it's going to
take into back
[Laughter]
yeah I gotta see that it's so cool it's
really great yeah when you watch the
shot it's like it looks really good it's
so good yeah it's those guys are Genius
Like again I say this all the time but
if if I can't find a tutorial about
something I think it's impossible
because the the fact that these guys are
just doing all this crazy Cutting Edge
stuff that no one's even thought of
doing and they're committing like the
fate of this entire multi-million dollar
film on just being like we'll find a way
yeah
man the cojones is so exciting to like
to imagine being
there during that time and being like
let's figure out how to do this that's
so cool yeah thank you that's awesome
another like on implosions uh and in
Star Wars was in Solo the um oh yeah the
water bombs those were crazy cool they
took like super high speed Phantom
footage of just like I guess like little
like m80s exploding underwater Oh and
they use that for the explosions because
they were like these weird kind of
charges that then sucked in and it's
just they also 3D scanned the mountains
yeah and then built it as a 3D model in
the water tanks the explosion would wrap
around the Rocks correctly yeah yeah so
you can comp it on to like actual
Collision geometry it's like yeah yeah
real world Collision geometry so like
when you see the bombs go off and like
it looks like an underwater shock wave
explosions like that's because it's 100
real under a lot of bombs going on
that's the last like explosion like VFX
thing that really I was like oh that is
I haven't seen that before like that's
what I like that's like that's the kind
of stuff I want to see yeah it's so cool
yeah I wonder if we've even discovered
all of the physical elements that happen
in real life when different types of
explosions happen in different types of
environments I wonder I'm sure there's
some like intricacies that are Beyond
like that I'm sure if his I'm sure
physicists are on top of it but like I'm
sure there's like little interactions
that are beyond what we're even you know
talking about yeah I mean we're always
discovering something new I'm sure that
they have it pretty well boiled down
given how sophisticated we are with
combustion as a concept yeah yeah
um but there's it's just what is it you
know there's like all these little
things that still separate
um
real
well they're from here's a here's a
weird funny thing so like when I started
this college there was a just a one-off
lecture that you could go to which is a
lecture on explosives and they
demonstrated all of them it was super
cool
yeah it was such a great lecture just
blowing stuff up and they're like all
right so let's talk about explosives uh
first off this is like the military
grade uh stuff that we use in all our
bombs uh this works like this here's the
chemical process for this and we'll blow
up just at the time did they do did they
do a Fusion uh they didn't do any Fusion
okay they did do nitroglycerin uh and
then they brought something that's even
more volatile uh it's like they put in
like a drop of it on a piece of paper
actually it was already on the paper
like they wheel the thing on carefully
and they take a feather and they're like
they brush it with the feather goes bang
it just explodes whoa whoa wow but I
learned that there's actually two
definitions to explosions there's
conflagrations and there's detonations
and the difference between them is that
debt nations are super Sonic and they
demonstrated like here's the thing that
will detonate it'll be supersonic it's
going to create a supersonic shock wave
but you know it's not gonna be super
loud to plug your ears you know bam it's
just like you know it's like wow that's
really concussive and like and here's
something that conflagrates like a
firecracker and they're like that you
know bang but it's not creating a
detonation it's not creating a shock
wave a sonic boom so that's where they
draw the line in terms of distinguishing
yep so all the stuff you see in movies
are conflagrations they are not
detonations but oftentimes they're
mimicking what are actually detonations
in real life and like that that shock
wave that Sonic Boom the difference of
it being Mach 1 and and faster like
really changes the look of things and
that's that's one of the things that I'm
kind of hoping to see more of is like if
we are doing CGI explosions like you
can't do detonative explosions
on set for obvious reasons like because
something that's putting off supersonic
shock waves like that's a dangerous
explosion right you're gonna you're
gonna mess stuff up and it's also like
you'll hear it for like for very far
um so you got to do conflagrations you
got to make them look like detonations
like you know your mortar hits and
you're like your Sandy explosions and
like they're all just lifting things
that's you know that's why they're
called lifters right but like you're
trying to make them look like actual
explosives going off that have
detonative power I'm gonna start using
that on set yep say hey Khan feel great
that
I think that building conflagrates and
there's a good conflagration out here
such a flexster that's a great word but
you know it's like if you get into CGI
it's like well let's start seeing some
things that like represent power like
yeah it's like for example what happens
in a Dead Nation all the dust lifts off
the ground right the dust lifts off
every surface uh you know you see
people's like clothing and hair move as
a Shockwave hits them like and these are
the things that cue us to be like that
was powerful yeah it's the same thing
like with Gunner effects you know yeah
it's like that's what I want to start
seeing it's like you're going to do a
similar explosion cool the moment the
explosion goes off I want to see the
dust lift off every surface I want to
see people's clothes Ripple I want to
see the glass windows Flex you know it's
like yeah let's just conflagrate
something on set that's easier I'm so
excited for Oppenheimer I'm really
curious to see how that's going to look
because like Nolan's known for doing
practical stuff but I'm curious how much
of it's going to be practical like yeah
do you know when they're doing nuclear
tests the you can actually see the light
from in La you'd see like the sky light
up wow yeah just insane yeah kind of
terrifying I would like to well no I
shouldn't say that yeah
we'll do an NCG one day from when they
were well there's a there's an old Side
in New Mexico you mean from that like
that far away yeah when they're doing it
in the desert okay yeah the the light
would travel you can see it do they do
them in Nevada as well I don't know
there's a place in New Mexico called
White Sands and
I believe that they do them there they
might do jets there I'm not sure
but it's a very large you can see it
from a space map it's just this huge
section of white sand in New Mexico
I don't know crazy yeah
such a rarity to have seen a nuclear
explosion what a rare thing for you in
person yeah yeah not something I want
because it's not radiation feel that
just kicked you in the team we only have
we can only imagine what that would have
looked like yeah hey if you've ever seen
a nuclear explosion for reals or know
someone that has leave a comment below I
mean we've seen you know there's the
there's the footage but even from the
it's hard to judge the scale yeah
exactly hence the scale of explosions
video but seriously it's so hard to
judge a scale like yeah these bombs
going off yeah you know
yeah that footage of like the sailors on
the boat watching the nuke yeah and then
you see the shock wave travel they just
yeah just wreck them all it's
that's power
um
that was the internet I think it's yeah
I don't know which which bomb it was I'm
not sure there's there's one too where
they're like they're in the desert and
they're doing much smaller nukes but
they're still nukes and it's like
everybody's in the Foxhole nuke goes off
stand up we can get the shock wave it's
like it's not like blasting anybody off
their feet but it's still like whoa whoa
yeah and the sound must have been yeah
absurd yeah yeah I really I really hope
that like we get a similar thing to like
Interstellar where it's like oh we
actually figured out everything like how
it would look and it's like they nail it
oh yeah yeah like with the black hole
where it's like yeah that was crazy we
have nuclear explosions perfect the dust
lifts people rip like this with the
black people you can't yeah you can't
refute that that's how it looks though
like they'll be like we did the
calculations and this is how it looks
you can't go no it doesn't like but this
thing was with the black hole is then
like three years later or whatever they
got the actual imagery of it and they're
like oh yeah emailed it like is that
right yeah yeah right the movies but
wow holy smokes the fact that he wasn't
just like I don't know do something that
looks cool he was like not do this right
and then sure enough he's like there's
an image of light bending around a black
hole and to be fair it looks like a
blurry orange donut yeah yeah it looks
like you took a still from Interstellar
scaled it down made it blur yeah like
you know 10 pixels by 240. yeah but it's
like it's enough that you're like
that's close enough they probably tinted
at Orange to make it look like
Interstellar probably yeah too yeah
but in just that that was really cool to
me I'm like oh wow they they like did
the math what a terrifying concept a
black hole is dude and there aren't they
making one on Earth
this might not be real I don't know but
some they were talking Jamie
but I read that this morning that
someone someone somewhere we don't even
know what they are maybe it was just a
hole I don't know
all we know is that they're so vacuumous
that they draw in the lights the lights
you have everything that's beyond the
point of no return which there's a word
for that I forgot
no it's not the singularity it's oh yeah
yeah so you'd see you'd see light freeze
on the horizon yeah you'd see uh if if
you saw me get sucked into a black hole
the last thing you'd see is me like
about to go in it you're just like but
my light would never you just stay there
yeah but I'd be deep in and crushed
already but it'd just be me and the
whole concept of what they are just
comes from that knowledge we don't know
what's beyond them oh man I'm waiting
for Andromeda to collide with us that's
what I'm waiting for I gotta I got a
ways to go I think you got a few million
years what I heard is they ran some Sims
on that like and the spacing of all the
stars and planets are so vast that even
though these two galaxies will collide
and like yeah
and will be absorbed by Andromeda nope
Star Planet I know but no Star Planet
will touch because it's over space like
but everything will be on fire
everything in the whole entire galaxy
will be on fire because of the the
energy in this thing and I'm like dang
dude that's crazy no one make a wish to
live forever because you'll have to
enjoy that one in person
you've
[Music]
yeah if everything is especially I think
that you fish yes you'll be on fire for
millions of years well that's even more
terrifying because then you see everyone
you love die and you feel nothing
burning alone feeling nothing for
Millions of beers that's just that
sounds like yeah
honorable achieve Galactic Civilization
by then and figure out a way to survive
it oh man I don't know dude well we're
getting further away from all the other
planets and stars
all the time like unless we fold space
and time
yeah
the lack of knowledge I have on this is
it's so irresponsible and I read an
illustrated history of time okay thank
you Stephen Hawking like this is the
part where you hold a piece of paper
like if this is space we figured out how
to and you fold it over you punch like a
pencil
we can slip out the back okay after that
anyway can we just pause for a second
what the hell is that so you're telling
well you're gonna tell me let me get
this piece
foreign
[Music]
right we're here and there there and if
we just do this that's it
like the master of the universe pretty
much yeah
like that's like saying like Okay so
we're on Earth here's Earth it's a ball
you're here and you're here but what if
we took this side and we've wrapped it
around that way yeah black holes are
just fast travels what do you mean of
course that would work if you could do
that why would you just assume that this
is possible I think there's math for
that I don't know I don't know this is
where I like to use the term I don't
know
there is math for it you would just need
an uncalculable amount of energy to be
able to do that yeah based on anyways
you need I don't know if I'm getting
into it I don't know physics well enough
it just seems like who just was like
just fold it it's like the fastest way
to save the fastest way to double your
money is to fold it and put it in your
pocket yeah
they're like take the same concept now
Wormhole I don't know it's fair it's a
fair criticism I feel like that was just
somebody in a Sci-Fi writer's room who
just just was just came up with it one
day this is perfect it describes exactly
what I want to do man there's nothing
like I don't know Jake have you ever had
to shoot like a science like low down
scene where it's like how are we going
to solve this well if we take this we
can do this and this will happen like
are you ready to shoot any of those
scenes of any guys Sam and I did one for
I'm a smart watch get over it that's
true it was a joke
this is the hardest scenes to shoot in
real life because from the moment it
starts you like like this is all Bs and
it's all made up yeah and I have to do
like not just like a few seconds of this
actually so I'll make like two minutes
of this interesting that was you for an
entire show on Lifeline yeah pretty much
like how do you get people to care about
all this made up the state of jargon
yeah
man we had a scene in Lifeline so
the breath before
Lifeline it's fun it's you know the idea
is that if you die
um it sends a signal a month into the
future where an agent then travels back
in time 33 days to be exactly three days
uh to change you from dying so basically
they've they paired you up and you put
on a Lifeline bracelet or implant and
they're just they're moving along their
timeline you know it tells you like oh
30 days from now this person's gonna die
so then they you know jump back in time
and they try to save them and the whole
idea is that when you jump you're
stepping into a new timeline therefore
not allowing new possibilities because
in the timeline where they died they
died you know
um so you know it's Time time travel is
all made up stuff
and so we had this scene where the main
character jumps in time but he jumps
into a timeline where he already exists
and he jumps only back like five minutes
so now he jumps to a timeline where
everything he's just like everything
that his character is doing he will be
doing in five minutes and like so we
haven't seen that we that we kind of
co-wrote with you know like the the
Show's actual writers where you know he
does that he does a scene he's like
what's going on he's like it all makes
sense in five minutes and he's like what
he's like trust me because he's talking
to himself and you know the Scene goes
on and then the scene finishes there's a
knock on the door and he goes oh and
opens it it's him from five minutes ago
and he's like what's going on it's like
and he's like it all makes sense in five
minutes trust me he follows his own path
right
um so he did this when he explained how
like you know time loops on itself and
if you like do this wrong you double up
and hence the two of you being right
here which goes on to like the climax
you know he's trying to save this girl's
life and he can only do it by having two
of himself and so that's how he does it
to create two of himself by doing that
uh but he also knows that once he does
that he's stuck on the path that his
other self is going to take
um super cool concept it's like you're
doing a time travel show you gotta do
that kind of stuff and they cut the
scene where he talks to himself and he
meets himself in the whole like you know
they do the time Loop in five minutes
things like ah really guys like it's
like being like do we need this trench
run like in Star Wars
can you just like shoot it and yeah yeah
I mean the Death Star blows up just get
it the first time yeah they just cut to
the ship and then shoots a missile and
it blows up that turns from like yeah
that concept sounds like something
Nathan Fielder would do after the
rehearsal yeah that's like yeah yeah
there's two of me but if I talk to
myself
I don't know I feel they're literally
Advanced cloning technology
wow man why did they ever tell you why
they cut that they thought it was
confusing it's like but isn't wasn't it
important time travel do you think about
this at all if it so we're going to
learn more things as Humanity goes
forward
do you think there's gonna be a point
where physicists are going to look at
this moment in time and go why the hell
that every time humans decided started
talking about physics they started
talking about time travel
or
the alternate universe they're like how
do they know
or maybe they were like wow they were
they already knew it back then hmm huh
or are we just way off you know look
when I was like eight years old see I
know there's not gonna be any time
travel in our lifetimes because when I
was eight-year-old I wrote down a piece
of Lifetime date time and location and I
told myself all right I'm gonna keep
this piece of paper with me forever and
if we invent a time machine I'll go
right back to this place at this time
which is in 10 minutes from now and I
waited
in the future my future for sure my
version of myself never showed up so I'm
like up I guess it doesn't happen
Nico do you still have the piece of
paper
do you remember the date and time I
roughly remember so maybe he did go back
but you'd already left okay the kid
version of you is like ah he's not
showing up and left but you were just
like two minutes later when I read The
Illustrated History of Time by Stephen
Hawking okay he explains time travel as
time and space because they're one right
as such if you have a car that's
traveling 88 miles per hour incredibly
fast
if it's traveling fast enough then the
front of the car will be at a different
time than the back of the car which
already just is crazy so but that is
true if you think about it it's like
okay well if there's a car it's
traveling and
you know this is the front of the car
this is the back of the car it does take
time no matter how fast it's going for
the back of the car to get there but
it's not noticeable
because it's ultimately I think he's
more saying that just by moving at
different speeds well is it the front
back of the car or is it just the car
versus everybody around you like you
know technically people that go up in
the space station have age slower than
people on the ground faster
but I don't understand how which makes
sense okay time and space is the same
thing
[Music]
it kind of does make sense if you think
about them as as as as as soon as one
cohesive thing yeah because you can't
describe something's okay somebody's
location without actually including the
time exactly yeah so time space they're
the same thing great I get that it makes
makes sense to me anyway but what I
don't understand is why all of a sudden
we think we could
like but what if I wasn't there you know
what if we time travel
it's like so time and space travel I
don't get it yeah
I don't I mean it's a great concept I
love it as like a Sci-Fi conduit for
storytelling it can be super fun
but there's people who are seriously
into it well and then the whole and I
just don't I don't maybe I need to read
up more but maybe there's somebody who's
making sense out there about time travel
if there is please I don't think I don't
think anyway about that I don't think
because the whole idea is like I watch
Donnie Darko and he was very convinced
okay if we all time traveled right now
like
five years from now
earth the earth rotating the Earth's
moving like we'd be phased inside a
building or something you know like if
you went from exactly this spot so it
doesn't need to be there's no absolute
points in space yeah like that's another
thing yeah yeah and there's no absolute
points in time
which makes sense because they're the
same thing yeah
there's no origin point maybe there is
maybe there's one grand origin point we
just don't know it well it's the big
bang is there the center of the Big Bang
is the uh zero zero zero
do you think do you think that on the
other side of a black hole is a big bang
oh hmm you think so I maybe I mean I
don't know it might just be a bang it
might not be that big yet oh it's their
big bang it's just our big bang already
happened we're good we already got it
doesn't have a lifter yet yeah it
doesn't have a lifter yet I don't I
always think about what the heck is you
know space is expanding but I'm sure you
guys thought about this all the time
what the heck is on the other side of it
well no he's basically just expanding
isn't like things are traveling away
from us like literally space itself is
expanding yes everybody's ballooning
yeah something getting pushed out like
even ourselves we are ballooning
literally all of spaces what's outside
of the of the bubble of it there's no
there's no it's not a bubble like as in
literally like
everything's expanded we're switching to
anamorphic
inside the bubbles the same in the
outside of the bubble's expanding it's
like literally no everything is
spreading out yeah if I if I if I kept
my two fingers like this for
eternity they would be spreading out the
little atoms my finger would be
spreading out like as in like everything
is spreading out yeah I hadn't heard
that we're scaling it yes like as in
space is literally think about working
out man I'm gonna expand physically
regardless think about it in physics
terms what's beyond that I mean
ultimately I don't it would be infinite
if if the universe is as we know it
expanding and it's infinite which we
don't know for sure but we don't have
any other reason to believe otherwise
but at the point of the Big Bang well
that's why that's why we think that
there's a big bang because we don't know
we don't know for sure it's not like we
can go back in time yeah there it is
here I am outside of known existence
that would be one hack observing
conflicting
space is the best thing in the world man
it makes no sense to me yeah and I just
love it all just like exist like things
are normal except there are like deep
paradoxes that we just ignore yeah and
we're just like sitting there like mad
at traffic or something like this
matter and you just zoom out and we're
just these little Speckles on this
little speckle and this little speckle
yeah big fat black hole turns into a
little speckle and it just keeps going
and it looks like if you look at the
fully mapped observable universe looks
exactly like microbiology to where you
wonder if you keep zooming out are you
getting this is this is the ending of
Men In Black right here yeah what's
getting a Men In Black it zooms out and
does the whole thing this and the cats
okay
with inside of the cat's collar there
are aliens playing with the marble dude
but I it's who's to say well I mean you
can't keep going you don't know yeah and
it could be that yeah
we're like the atoms in God or something
and we're just like yeah you know it's
like who who the heck knows what the
heck I don't know man look Bonkers CGI
explosions need to get on it because
real life explosions might be the atoms
and God
that's that all makes okay that makes
sense so so Jake yeah what are you
changing the name of the podcast to
uh we have been discussing that but I
feel like we've done a nice
Sprint here on explosions and all and
all the relative physics we can't help
it yeah it's impossible you've managed
to like hold our tongues in AI this time
but it was hard yeah yeah
so anyways thanks for joining us
everybody
um and uh well I guess we'll see you
here next time to talk about the name
change to talk about
skydiving
I did that
um
I want to hear about that so yeah yeah
all right well all right well later on
everybody's in God be well goodbye
yeah
yeah